the government's austerity policy and
all of our constituents can see the
consequences of this in delays in
responding to 999 calls and rising
violent crime will we see the chart slur
today offering any additional funding
for policing the fear must be that the
government will not even properly fund
the police pension second
mr. speaker the right honorable lady is
right to talk about policing and the
incredible work the officers and staff
do but it's worth reminding the house
that it was labor that plan to cut
police spending by five to ten percent
have they won the 2015 election in 2017
labor did for massive increase but it
wasn't enough sir because we increased
it by more than what labour promised by
four hundred sixty million and labor
then went our honor to vote against the
increase there's not a single Labour MP
that voted for an increase in police
funding where they had the opportunity
to do so so we're not gonna take any
lectures from Labour on policing the GC
David question turn mr. speaker
the government is very concerned about
increases in knife crime and its impact
on victims families and communities the
action we are taking is set out in our
serious violence strategy and includes
new legislation and the offensive
weapons bill for Community Fund to
support local initiatives the hashtag
knife free media campaign and continuing
police action under operation sector
david TC day mr. speakers the minister
knows that police and Criminal Evidence
Act currently prevents the police from
using past criminal criminal convictions
as grounds for determining whether a
search is proportionate would she
consider changing pace so that people
who have stopped for a legitimate reason
and who have found to have a recent
criminal conviction for carrying knives
can actually be searched by a police
officer well of course my humble friend
brings his experience as a special
constable into the chamber I'm grateful
to him for his service
we are clear that stopping search is a
vital policing tool and we're committed
to tackling knife crime under the police
and Criminal Evidence Act effect
officers already have the power to
search an individual they suspect be
carrying a knife we therefore believe
current proposals to be proportionate
but we will keep them under review and
continue to work closely with the police
to ensure they have the tools they meet
I'll be happy to meet the Honorable
friend to discuss further mr. speaker
the Home Secretary announced in
September they would adopt the public
health approach to tackling knife crime
and measure the youth violence
Commission recommended following strong
evidence that it works can the Home
Secretary tell me when the house will be
given the opportunity to debate this
vital issue extremely grateful to the
Honorable lady for the work she does on
the with the Commission and indeed other
members across the house she will know
through our scrutiny of the offensive
weapons bill how seriously we take the
public health approach and this is
something that we have this is something
that we have looked at through the
development of the serious violence
strategy she will know that there was a
debate before the summer recess on
serious violence but I'm always happy as
she knows to debate how we help support
our police forces in tackling this
terrible strong pressure on time today
I'm afraid given on in rake mr. Ben
Wallace we've made significant progress
international crime agency was
established in 2013 capabilities have
improved partnership working is better
and we intervene earlier to prevent
serious organized crime the agency has
gone from strength to strength with an
impressive and sustained track record of
disruptions across the full range of
serious and organised crime threats
Timmy's Valley Police spent seven
million pounds investigating the H boss
reading banking scandal would my right
hand will offend consider establishing
regional fraud squads which we
self-funded from the proceeds were both
finds and recovered recovered funds to
to properly investigate business banking
fraud and
Financial Crimes the Honorable member my
humble friend suggestion is similar to
what already happened through the
organized organized region organized
crime units in which we have injected a
hundred and forty million pounds in
grant funding to help establish them but
also to ensure that we put in place the
right financial investigators in each
region to tackle fraud the organized
crime crosses borders and the nca rely
on the european arrest warrant databases
and joint operations with Europe all all
of which will fall if we leave the EU
without a deal in place in April given
that Ireland has repealed its
extradition arrangements for the
previous 8 1957 convention will there be
any legal way to extradite organised
criminals from Dublin if there is no
deal the right honourable lady makes a
very important point about what happens
post brexit she would of course know
that the negotiations of Michele Barnea
are all about issues like that now I
suspect Ireland will go along with
whatever the European Union's deal is to
implement and we are seeking a security
treaty in order that we can put in place
many of these very very important
measures a sentence perhaps Lloyd
Russell moil organized crime often leads
to bad drugs on our streets and one of
the ways to stop that of course is drug
testing in festivals the minister agreed
that he would write to police forces
about the legality of this what is the
response in Easter I I think what the
best thing is for the honourable members
suggestion is to hear what he says we've
got to stem the demand for drugs both
recreational and by other users and
therefore it's important that we work
with Leif to deliver that West 3G Thank
You mr. speaker question 12 surgery we
will be launching a 200 million pound
Youth endowment fund to intervene with
children at risk of serious violence
will be consulting on a new duty to
support multi-agency approach to
tackling violence and undertaking review
of drug misuse
we're strange Thank You mr. speaker the
recent murder of a 23 year old man in my
constituency has once again brought the
issue of violent crime to the forefront
of concerns in my community my
constituents understand that whether in
labor led cities like London or Tory
shires the reality is that cuts to
police numbers are having a serious
impact which is leading to increases in
violent crime across the country when
will the Home Secretary accept this and
put the money back into the police our
communities need mr. speaker the
Honorable Jeffers are absolutely right
to raise this and he will know the
governor has a cross government serious
violence strategy but we do need to do
more and that's why I recently announced
these further steps especially the new
200 million pound fund which will help
prevent violence right or a friend agree
that we need to remain committed to
steering young and often vulnerable
people away from crime what's the
department doing to strike a balance
between prevention and robust law
enforcement Minister my honourable
friend is right to race this we have
this new 200 million pound fund that was
announced earlier this month and we also
have an early intervention Youth Fund of
22 million pounds
Nicko the Home Secretary might not want
to take any lessons from labor on
policing but in March hm I see warned
the lives of vulnerable policing could
be at risk if cuts continue in May the
Metropolitan Police Commissioner said
she was certain his government's cuts
have contributed to violent crime in
September the NAO warned that the home
office does not know if police forces
are financially sustainable and last
week the Home Affairs Select Committee
declared the police could become
irrelevant without serious investment in
today's budgets every one of these
warnings have been ignored by government
can he tell us why he thinks they're all
wrong and he's right mr. speaker of
course the the police's need to have the
right mix of resources as well as other
factors and that's why we've increased
police funding this year by over 460
million pounds but the Honourable lady
also knows it's not all about resources
so for example the changes in drug
markets are playing a big role that's
why I hope she'd welcome the review that
I've recently announced the government
is committed to protecting the rights of
asylum seekers and ensures that those
who would otherwise be destitute are
provided with accommodation and other
support to meet their essential living
needs we continue to work closely with
local government the devolved
administration's the private sector and
the civil society to make improvements
to the services that are provided this
diva mr. speaker the minister will be
aware that following a legal challenge
in Scotland supreme courts by two of my
constituents and govern law center CF
court undertook to British law change
evictions on halls however as the
minister aware the circle are
threatening to Epperly
my constituents retina with locked
change of actions via key now that's
completely unacceptable
I know she invested
it is important that the Home Office
continues the work with surco with
Glasgow City Council and indeed NGO
partners as part of a dedicated task
force to make sure that all those
individual who are no longer entitled to
a silence support or accommodation and
managed appropriately he is of course
right to point out that following the
legal challenge by his constituents no
service users have been evicted whilst
this appeal is still ongoing
finally bumble Cheryl ambos
[Applause]
and number 14 mr. speaker Minister heard
mr. speaker as taxpayers we are
investing over a billion pounds more in
our police system than we were three
years ago recognition by this government
about the increasing demand and
complexity of demand on police but also
recognition of the progress we are
making in reducing the deficit in our
public finances a progress jeopardized
by the current labor front pending boss
chair alum bus the minister will no
doubt be aware of the lamentable
findings of the recently published Home
Affairs Select Committee report policing
for the future does he agree with the
reports inclusions that without
additional funded funding for policing
there'll be dire consequences to the
public safety criminal justice human
cohesion and public confidence and would
he join me in calling for this
Chancellor to write substantially more
funding for policing in mics it's an
event filled South captain across the
country yes I agree with much of the the
report from the husk committee including
the need for more resources for Pisa
which is exactly what we are doing
through an additional investment of 460
million pound by taxpayers in our police
system this year a police settlement
that he and other Labour MPs voted
against all the topical questions Chris
Stephen no bar one sir I'm sorry mr.
speaker has been a busy few weeks of a
home office as we continue in our
efforts to deliver for the British
people on Thursday regulations allowing
their medicinal use of cannabis based
products will come into effect providing
relief to those people particularly
children who have known so much pain and
I will shortly visiting the United
States to monitor progress on my
challenge to tech giants to help us
fight the child sexual exploitation for
those who fall short there were no place
to hide Christine Thank You mr. speaker
my constituent and Freddie was supposed
to be moved by circle to a new social
housing accommodation following a
successful claim however that did not
happen and Safeco removed beds heating
and 22 pounds 50 paints and cash to see
Secretary of State believe that circle
are
row provider of services should be
removed from the contract Minister Mr
Speaker I'm happy to take a closer look
at the case that he mentions the oral
gentle mentions but he will know that
we've consulted on a new approach with
the Scottish Government with local
government with others and we're
confident that the new approach will see
a significant improvement over the last
few months we have actually seen a
reduction in moped crime does this show
what can be achieved when we take a
multi-agency approach where resources
are allocated and crucially where the
police are allowed to pursue
motorcyclists even though they're not
wearing crash ovis ministered MP I'm
absolutely delighted that moped crime is
down about 50% off it's terrible peak
and that's a result of superb police
action but also the work convened by the
Home Office bringing together government
industry and civil society to bear down
on this problem
so pleased are we that we're taking that
model forward to tackle vehicle crime
thank you Mr Speaker I thank max Hill QC
for his work as the reviewer of
counter-terror legislation on leaving on
the 12th of October to become Director
of Public Prosecutions
but given his departure was announced on
the 24th of July why has no success have
been appointed
why has the post been left vacant with
counter tower legislation going through
Parliament what on earth is the Home
Office excuse for this sheer negligence
we are about to start the process for
his predecessor but but but to suggest
that this has somehow held progress back
on counterterrorism would be completely
incorrect the new counterterrorism
strategy was just launched a few months
ago and that sets out clearly how
seriously the government takes this
really a matter of the utmost
sensitivity and and the right honourable
lady's question must be heard I think
with solemnity and respect this is
Theresa Villiers Thank You mr. speaker
in the light of the horrors of
Pittsburgh can the Home Secretary
provide the reassurance that both
government and the police will always
take very very seriously the security of
the Jewish community and other
minorities who may be subjected to hate
crimes and violence
Mr Speaker I can absolutely provide my
right or my friend that reassurance in
fact just this weekend
following that tragedy I spoke to the
head of the community security trust who
to offer that reassurance it's an
organization we're proud to support but
we want to look at new ways about
helping that the community with its own
security needs
it is sad in this day and age that any
community needs security of that type
but for as long as it does we will
always be there and tonight I will be
also attending a vigil to mark what
happened at Pittsburgh that terrible
tragedy thank you
Luciana bersia
the perpetrator of the Pittsburgh
murders has a history of posting the
most vile anti-semitism Islamophobia and
threatening comments and similarly the
man is suspected of sending pipe bombs
to prominent Democrats threaten the life
of a political commentator via a tweet a
few months ago but Twitter said that it
didn't violate its online documents in
the wake of this these terrible
tragedies what is the government doing
to address the very serious issue of
online hate mr. speaker the Honorable ad
is again right to raise this and we've
seen the role that social medias play
not just in Britain but abroad in in
feeding hate and that's one of the
reasons we just recently refreshed as
government are the the anti hate
strategy that the government has and
this is exactly one of the things we'll
be looking into further quasi because
this summer roads we saw a number of
illegal gypsy and traveler encampments
on new housing sites now our local
councillor Jill Simpson Vince brought
together developers and Warwickshire
police to put a protocol in place could
the secretary state encourage others to
follow Warwick Sears leads blended thank
you to speaker yes I can leave art in
Thank You mr. speaker
what progress is he made in compensating
Windrush victims who've been made
homeless and jobless by the government's
hostile environment minister names I
thank the Honourable member for that
question he will know that Martin Ford
QC recently asked the government and we
agreed to extend the consultation period
for the compensation scheme so that we
can make sure that we get the best
responses possible and so that he can
engage more widely with the community in
exceptional circumstances the Home
Office has already made payments to some
individuals you Steve DuBose to speak up
meat and fish processing businesses in
my constituency rely heavily on migrant
workers many of their staff are highly
trained even though our highly skilled
even though their skill is not formally
recognized by a qualification what steps
are the government taking to make sure
that these sort of skills are properly
recognized in our future immigration
policy
pick our food and drink in the streets
vital to the success of our economy and
I know that many Cornish businesses are
very successful in this sector I can
reassure my honourable friend that we
will be taking these issues very
seriously as we develop our new
immigration system my constituent mr.
Jenkins has was born and bred in
Bridgend his wife of over 20 years has
been told she has to leave the day
before their child's 18th birthday why
what sort of hostile environment
destroys family life in that way
Minister if the Honourable lady would
care to write to me I'd look closely at
the case that you mentioned baganz
speaker next March we'll see the 40th
anniversary of the assassination a
brutal assassination of Airey Neave on
these premises aranese family my
constituents are seeking more
information about the circumstances of
the murder I've been told that my
questions on this had been transferred
from the niño to the Home Office but
will my right honourable friend the Home
Secretary agreed to meet with me an area
needs family to discuss how they can get
answers on how and why Airey Neave was
murdered 40 years ago yes Mr Speaker I
will recharge
what will the Home Secretary do to help
police forces prioritize resources when
they have faced with cannabis clubs of
which most members require cannabis for
medicinal reasons and an epidemic of
spice at the same time which poses very
serious risks to both health and oral
order but which are both Class B drugs
well operating priorities are local are
local decisions what I can say to the
Honourable lady is the variety of of the
department is make sure the police has
got the resources they need to do their
job which is why we took steps to
increase public investments in our
police policy will indeed reflect the
needs of the farming and fishing
community in Scotland and indeed the
whole of the UK
I can give my honourable friend that
insurance and that's also one of the
reasons we've recently launched a pilot
for a seasonal workers agricultural
scheme for 2019
[Music]
and we'll reverse the imposition
mr. well after the only way is aware
that West Midlands received more funding
this year nine point nine million pounds
in a police funding settlement she voted
against and I will be coming to the
house in early December with our
proposals for 2019-20 become a target
for unsafe behavior brought on by the
misuse of drugs and alcohol what more
can be done to ensure that we have a
visible police presence in our town
sensors and desirable friend agreed that
they're showing the back-office
functions with other emotions of
services to free up resources maybe with
the solution mr. [ __ ] I'm delighted
that I'm visiting my girlfriend on
Friday to see for myself the hard work
she does and taking care of her
constituents working alongside her local
police force but this government
supports greater collaboration and has
placed a statutory duty on police fire
and ambulance services to keep to
collaborative opportunities under review
and enter into them where the interests
of their efficiency were effective in
people's engines of our baozi and
liberalism there are vows Thank You mr.
speaker small and medium-sized
businesses are the lifeblood of most
local economies including my birth
constituency however they face many
challenges in recruiting attack and
Attalla many where the minister had said
on reforming the tio2 visa system to
make it easier and remove the
prohibitive cross for smaller and wise
recruit highly-skilled Elvises graduate
from UK universities I think it
contained quite a lot of semicolons
Minister Thank You mr. Speaker I shared
the Honorable members admiration for
small and medium-sized businesses the
country over the immigration system
already facilitates recruitment of
foreign graduates of UK universities by
waving many of the usual requirements we
will shortly be setting out our plans
for the future immigration system
following the recent report by the
migration Advisory Committee in Bradley
following on miyajima debate on the
subject and a letter from 20 police and
crime commissioners did the minister
confirm he shares my concerns about the
impact of Mumba and spice on communities
like Mansfield and they will consider
potential solutions to support the local
police and services in tackling this
issue I salute the tireless campaign by
my humble friend and another's spicies a
scourge of mini town centres environment
we take independent advice on
classification we keep that independent
advice under review but sadly her young
life was cut short 2015 she took an
overdose of ecstasy her mother
anne-marie now campaigns tirelessly for
a new evidence based approach to drugs
policy would the Secretary of State
consent to meeting Ann Marie to hear why
she believes a new approach is necessary
well I am of course very sorry to hear
that as I'm sure the entire houses the
Honourable member will know that the
Home Secretary has commissioned an
independent review of drugs so that we
may understand better how drugs are used
in the 21st century and of course I
would be honored to meet her and her
constituent to discuss this Thank You
mr. speaker when we leave the European
Union we will of course have control of
all aspects of immigration policy does
the Home Secretary agree that we can
then prioritize the highest skills
immigration as a way of boosting our
nation's productivity
yes I agree with my own war friend
that's exactly what we'll do and then
we'll set out the approach in the white
paper in a few weeks time is twist since
2010 Northumbria Police there's already
less [ __ ] cops and lost a thousand
jobs now faces in an additional cost
from an employer pension contributions
of 11 million equivalent to 220 offices
have the minister pressed the Treasury
to fund this cost before even more
police jobs along its terms mr. speaker
her local police force will be getting
an extra five million pounds this year
and she also no later this year where
have the police in settlement something
I know should we look forward to
[Music]
[Applause]
cultural workers pilots in was warmly
welcomed tribal farmers and agricultural
bodies across the United Kingdom
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh Oh Dave the minister had hoped the
Minister heard our honourable friend she
did otherwise we'll have to have a
represe Minister my honourable friend
for her question and was delighted to me
to go to her constituency over the
summer to meet soft fruit farmers who
made a very compelling case for a
seasonal workers scheme and she will be
no doubt delighted that the government
is having a pilot on the horticultural
sector to make sure that they can access
the labor that they need as that new
young member John speller are their ears
let's hear the fella Thank You mr.
speaker and I hope the Home Secretary
will answer this question because the
reality is in the West Midlands Police
area crime is escalating and the
overstretched under under stark police
are feeling deeply frustrated as the
criminals and the gangs take control of
the streets especially at night when's
he going to stop the rot give the
backing give the resources to our police
out there on the street every day
[Applause]
mr. speaker the gentleman though West
Midlands Police had an increase of
almost 10 million pounds this year
however it is always worth listening to
local forces I'm happy to meet with West
Midlands MPs that I have done in the
past and listened more thank you order
[Applause]
at least we know civil raises folk debt
order order before I call the Chancellor
of the Exchequer I must remind
honourable members that copies of the
budget resolutions will be available in
the votes office at the end of the
Chancellor's speech
I also remind honourable members that it
is not the norm to intervene on the
Chancellor of the Exchequer or the
leader of the Opposition
I know called the Chancellor of the
Exchequer the right honourable Philip
Hammond Thank You mr. Deputy Speaker
today I present to the House of budget
for Britain's future a budget that shows
the perseverance of the British people
finally paying off a budget for
hardworking families who live their
lives far from this place and care
little for the twists and turns of
Westminster politics people who get up
early every morning who open up
factories shops and building sites drop
their kids off at school check on
elderly relatives and neighbors the
strivers the grafters and the carers who
are the backbone of our communities
people who ask only of government that
we protect the jobs that put food on
their table that we deliver the public
services their families rely on and that
we do it efficiently minimizing the
amount of tax we need to take from their
hard-earned wages people mr. Deputy
Speaker who we on this side of the house
are proud to represent so I say to them
today this budget is unashamedly for you
mr. Deputy Speaker the British people
put their faith in us to do the job and
today we repay that trust with a budget
that paves the way for a brighter future
a mr. Deputy Speaker let me be clear why
the tough decisions of the past eight
years were not driven by ideology
mr. Deputy Speaker they were not driven
by ideology they were driven
they were driven by necessity and by the
failure of the party opposite in
government
which led to our deficit soaring to a
post-war record and our economy
suffering the deepest recession since
the Second World War that mr. Deputy
Speaker was our inheritance and as ever
we did what needed to be done
now we have reached a defining moment on
this long hard journey
opening a new chapter in our country's
economic history where we can look
confidently to the future and set our
course for where this remarkable country
will go next because today mr. Deputy
Speaker I could report to the British
people that their hard work is paying
off and the era of austerity is finally
coming to an end
[Applause]
now mr. Deputy Speaker I am sure like me
many members of the house keenly
remember the last budget delivered on a
Monday it was 1962 I was six years old
tensions between Russia and the United
States were rising and a former foreign
secretary turned Chancellor delivered a
budget amid cabinet revolt mr. Deputy
Speaker I am acutely aware of the
phenomenon of false memory but I could
swear I remember my parents turning to
me and saying Philip one day that could
be
[Laughter]
mr. Debora speaker the the media has
been full of speculation about the
timing of today's budget some were
hoping for a December budget I'm sure
the headline writers were ready with
something like spreadsheet filter and
Santa Clause
others were desperate others were
desperate others were desperate for it
to be on Wednesday hammo house of
horrors perhaps but the truth the truth
is by choosing today rather than
Wednesday
I have not avoided the blood-curdling
threats the anguish wailing and the
strange banging of furniture that's
usually associated with Wednesday I've
been kindly invited to a special meeting
of the 1922 committee this evening mr.
Deputy Speaker our economy continues to
confound those who talk it down and we
continue to focus resolutely on the
challenges and opportunities that lie
ahead as we build a new relationship
with our European neighbors a new future
outside the European Union but as we do
so let us not forget the remarkable
achievements of the British people in
clearing up the aftermath of Labor's
Great Recession
because mr. Deputy Speaker for all
Labour's carping and relentless
negativity talking Britain down at every
opportunity we the British people have a
record to be proud of eight straight
years of economic growth over 3.3
million more people in jobs higher
employment and lower unemployment in
every region and every nation of the
United wages wages growing at their
fastest pace in almost a decade
income inequality lower now than at any
time under the last Labour government an
economy back on its feet again an
economy working not for the few not even
for the many an economy working for
everyone
[Applause]
mr. Deputy Speaker we're at a pivotal
moment in our EU negotiations and the
stakes could not be higher get it right
and we will not only protect Britain's
jobs businesses and prosperity but we
will also harvest a double-deal dividend
a boost from the end of uncertainty and
a boost from releasing some of the
fiscal Headroom that I am holding in
reserve at the moment we are confident
that we will secure a deal which
delivers that dividend confident but not
complacent mr. Deputy Speaker so we will
continue to plan for all eventualities
and I will do so at this budget with a
three pronged approach first I have
already allocated 2.2 billion pounds to
departments for brexit preparations and
in the autumn budget last year I set
aside a further 1.5 billion pounds to be
allocated for 2019-20 today I am
increasing that sum to 2 billion pounds
and in the coming weeks the chief
secretary will announce allocations to
individual departments secondly I shall
today maintain the Headroom to my fiscal
rules broadly as set out in the spring
statement retaining fire power to
intervene if the economy needs more
support in the coming months and thirdly
as I've been clear since moving to an
autumn budget if the economic or fiscal
outlook changes materially in year I
will take whatever action is appropriate
if necessary upgrading the spring
statement to a full fiscal event mr.
Deputy Speaker the house can be
confident that we are working for the
best outcome for Britain and preparing
for every eventuality mr. Deputy Speaker
I shall first report to the house on the
economic forecasts of the independent
OPR and I thank Robert Choate and his
team once again for their excellent work
the obr expect growth to be resilient
across the forecast period
improving next year from the 1.3 percent
forecast at the spring statement to 1.6
percent
then 1.4 percent in 2020 and 2021 1.5
percent in 2022 and 1.6 percent in 2023
mr. Deputy Speaker this government has
prioritized getting people into work
because the best way to help people is
to provide them with the stability of a
pay packet every month since 26 2010
over 3.3 million more people are in work
and today the obr confirm Britain's jobs
miracle is set to continue revising
revising up participation in the labor
market revising down the country's
equilibrium unemployment rate predicting
800,000 more jobs by 2023
[Applause]
by my calculation mr. Deputy Speaker
that's over 4.2 million net new jobs
since 2010 making the shadow
Chancellor's prediction of 1.2 million
jobs lost out by just the tiniest margin
of 5.4 million
roughly the population of Scotland but
now mr. Deputy Speaker we need to focus
on pay and with the proportion of low
paid jobs at its lowest since 1997 with
regular pay growth at 3.1 percent its
strongest in almost a decade and
inflation forecast to average two
percent next year the obr is forecasting
sustained real wage growth in each of
the next five years a far cry mr. Deputy
Speaker from the dismal picture that the
leader of the Opposition is so desperate
to pay every Wednesday
I turn now to the fiscal forecast we
inherited the highest budget deficit in
our peacetime history but after eight
years the hard work of the British
people is paying off and we will not
squander their efforts today's forecast
taking into an account all announcements
made since the spring statement
including measures I shall announce
today shows the deficit down from almost
10% under labor to less than 1.4 percent
next year under this conservative and
falling to just naught point 8 percent
by 2023
24 borrowing this year will be 11 point
6 billion pounds lower than forecast at
the spring statement just 1 point 2
percent of GDP and is then set to fall
from 31 point eight billion in 2019
twenty to twenty six point seven billion
in 2020 twenty one twenty three point
eight billion in twenty one twenty two
twenty point eight billion in 22 23 and
nineteen point eight billion in 23 24
its lowest level in over 20 years
[Music]
so mr. Deputy Speaker we meet our
structural borrowing target three years
early and deliver borrowing of just 1.3
percent of GDP in 2021 maintaining 15.4%
against our 2% fiscal rules target we
are no longer borrowing at all to
finance current spending and today the
obr confirm that our national debt
peaked in 2016-17 at eighty five point
two percent of GDP and then falls in
every year of the forecast from eighty
three point seven percent this year to
seventy four point one percent in twenty
three twenty four that is lower in every
year than forecast at the spring
statement and it means that we meet our
target to get debt falling three years
early a turning point in our nation's
recovery from Labour's Great Recession
both our fiscal rules met both of them
three years early
so mr. Deputy Speaker fiscal Phil says
fiscal rules okay
[Applause]
revisted every speaker
[Applause]
mr. Deputy Speaker while we are working
to get Britain's debt down to end the
nightmare of wasting over 50 billion
pounds a year on interest the party
opposite would do the opposite their
plans would increase tax and borrowing
by a thousand billion pounds taking our
debt to GDP ratio soaring to well over a
hundred percent of GDP a reckless and
irresponsible policy from a reckless and
irresponsible party
I've always been clear sound public
finances are essential but they are not
an end in themselves so since I've been
Chancellor I have taken a balanced
approach putting an additional 60
billion pounds into our public services
an investment in our future cutting tax
for 31 million people and all the while
reducing borrowing and getting our
national debt falling now we must do
more and thanks to the hard work of the
British people in this budget we can do
more I said at the spring statement that
our careful management of the public
finances was beginning to pay off and
that if the improvement we saw then
continued then I would be able to
provide more support to our public
services on a sustainable basis today
the OPR confirmed a significant
improvement in our public finances an
upgrade that underscores the hard work
of the British people and this
government stewardship of this economy
since 2010 which means I can deliver on
that promise I made in the spring
setting out a new path for public
spending and a clear view for the
British people of the fruits of their
hard work next year we will conduct a
full spending review setting our
priorities for public spending within a
sustainable funding envelope deciding on
the right balance between investing in
Britain's future and current consumption
of public services today I have set out
an indicative five-year path for
departmental resource spending or Ardell
as it's known to aficionados of public
finance
for context mr. Deputy Speaker in the
spending review 2010 average annual real
growth was minus 3% in the spending
review of 2015 it was minus one point
three percent from next year it will be
plus one point two percent average
annual real growth but that is not the
limit of my ambition when our EU
negotiations deliver a deal as I'm
confident they will I expect that the
deal dividend dividend will allow us to
provide further funding for the spending
review the hard work of the British
people is paying off austerity is coming
to an end
[Applause]
now mr. Deputy Speaker you will know
better than most that every Chancellor
likes to have a rabbit or two in his hat
as he approaches a budget but this year
this year some of my star bunnies appear
to have escaped just a little bit early
in June my right honourable friend the
Prime Minister announced the single
largest cash commitment to our public
services ever made by a peacetime
government an eight point four billion
pound five-year deal for our precious
NHS half as much again as the increased
labour offered the NHS at the last
election and let me be clear we are
delivering this historic twenty point
five billion pounds real terms increase
for the NHS in full over the next five
years so in a very important sense mr.
Deputy Speaker we made our big choice
for this budget four months before it
was delivered and this was the right
decision our NHS is the number one
priority of the British people and as we
approach the 70th anniversary of its
foundation they had a right to know the
scale of our commitment to it but the
British people also care that money
invested in the NHS goes to the front
line and to improvements in services so
we didn't just hand over money we agreed
that the NHS would produce a ten-year
plan setting out how the service will
reform how waste will be reduced and
exactly what the British people can
expect to get for their money that plan
will be published shortly but I shall
give the house a sneak preview today
there are
I - I - composure rabbit every now and
then there are many pressing demands on
additional NHS funding but few more
pressing than the needs of those who
suffer from mental illness and today I
can announce that the NHS 10-year plan
will include a new mental health crisis
service with comprehensive mental health
support available in every major ie
children and young people's crisis teams
in every part of the country more mental
health ambulances more safe havens in
the community and a 24-hour mental
health crisis hotline these new services
will ensure that people suffering from a
crisis young or old
can get the help they need ending the
stigma that has forced to many to suffer
in silence
and ending to the tragedy of too many
lives lost to suicide we are proud to
have made this extraordinary commitment
to funding our NHS a precious
institution that has been nurtured for
most of its life by conservative
governments
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. Deputy Speaker departmental spending
allocations will be settled at the
spending review next year however there
are a small number of areas where I will
provide further support now in order to
deliver necessary certainty for forward
planning local government has made a
significant contribution to repairing
the public finances and this budget
ensures local councils have more
resources to deliver high-quality public
services
we're giving councils greater control
over the money they raise through the
adult social care precept through our
plans for increased business rate
retention from 2020 and by removing the
housing revenue account cap so that
councils can help to build the homes
this country needs we will shortly
publish our green paper on the future of
social care setting out the choices some
of them difficult for making our social
care systems sustainable into the future
but I recognise the immediate pressures
local authorities face in respect of
social care so today building on the 240
million pounds for social care winter
pressures announced earlier this month I
will make available a further 650
million pounds of grant funding for
English authorities for 2019-20 and an
additional 45 million pounds for the
disabled facilities grant in England in
2018 19 and will invest a further 84
million pounds over the next five years
to expand our successful children's
social care programs to 20 further
councils with high or rising numbers of
children in care allowing councils to
improve services for older people for
people with disabilities and for
children in care now while longer-term
funding decisions will be made at the
spending review
mr. Deputy Speaker the UK spends more on
defense than any NATO member except the
u.s. but over the last year we've had
stark reminders of the scale scope and
complexity of the threats we face my
right honourable friend the defense
secretary is working with the Cabinet
Office and the Treasury to conduct a
review into the modernization of our
armed forces in response to the evolving
threat which will form the basis for a
comprehensive consideration of defense
spending next year but as a former
defense secretary myself I understand
the immediate pressures our armed forces
are facing so I will today provide an
additional 1 billion pounds to the mo D
to cover the remainder of this year and
next to boost our cyber capabilities and
our anti-submarine warfare capacity and
to maintain the pace of the dreadnought
program to ensure continuous at sea
deterrent a deterrent mr. Deputy Speaker
that allows us to sleep easy in our beds
but one that the leader of the
Opposition and his shadow chancellor
have spent their political lifetimes
campaigning to abolish
[Applause]
nobody should be in any doubt that on
this side of the house we are proud of
our armed forces
and we will always back them with the
investment they need to keep this
country safe
a mr. Deputy Speaker it is not only our
armed forces that keep us safe our
counterterrorism police play a vital
role in defending Britain against the
evolving threats we face we committed in
2015 to spend 30 percent more on
counterterrorism capabilities over the
current spending review period and today
I commit an additional hundred and sixty
million pounds of CT police funding for
twenty nineteen twenty to protect CT
police numbers in nineteen twenty and to
allow future CT police funding to be
considered in the round at the spending
review I recognize that policing more
generally is under pressure from the
changing nature of crime I also
recognized the representations made on
this by many colleagues such as my
honourable friend the member for
Southwest Bedfordshire and I can tell
the house today that my right honourable
friend the Home Secretary will review
police spending power and further
options for reform when he presents the
provisional police funding settlement in
December mr. Deputy Speaker as I have
already set out due to the hard work of
the British people public borrowing this
year is coming in substantially below
forecast this allows us to provide
additional support for public services
in the spending review and contributes
to the significant reduction in forecast
debt this year but I also want to use
this good news to give a little bit back
where it can be put to good use in this
financial year mr. Deputy Speaker this
year marks a scent century since the end
of the first world war and as we
remember our fallen servicemen and women
whose sacrifice ensured the freedom we
enjoy today many projects are raising
money for veterans charities from sales
of commemorative items on which VA tea
is judged now we cannot waive the v80 do
on these sales but we can make a
donation with the v80 we will receive
and I commit today that the Treasury
will mark the centenary of the armistice
by making a donation of 10 million
pounds to the Armed Forces covenant fund
trust to support veterans
mental health needs many of our nation's
village halls mr. Deputy Speaker were
built to commemorate the sacrifice of
World War one and many of them are being
refurbished to commemorate the centenary
so I will also provide funding for
grants equivalent to the VA T chargeable
on such refurbishment projects and as
our focus moves from the n anniversaries
of the First World War to the second I
will also provide 1.7 million pounds for
educational programs in schools to mark
the 75th anniversary of the liberation
of the Bergen Belsen concentration
College ensuring the next generation
hears the stories of those who survived
the Holocaust and of the British
soldiers who liberated them because mr.
Deputy Speaker as the terrible events in
Pittsburgh this weekend remind us the
battle against anti-semitism did not end
with the defeat of Nazi Germany
across the length and breadth of England
our air ambulance services worked
tirelessly to get those with
life-threatening illnesses and injuries
quickly to the expert medical care they
need funded entirely by philanthropy
they do a fantastic job and today I'm
making 10 million pounds of funding
available to help them go on doing so
mr. Deputy Speaker we are investing
record amounts in our schools and that
investment is paying off with 86 percent
of schools 86 percent of schools now
rated good or outstanding compared to 68
percent in 2010 but I recognize that
school budgets often do not stretch to
that extra bit of kit that would make
such a difference so today
today I'm announcing of 400 million
pound in year bonus to help our schools
buy the little extras they need a
one-off a one-off capital payment
directly to schools averaging 10,000
pounds per primary school and 50,000
pounds per secondary school
[Music]
mr. Deputy Speaker I have one final
in-year measure to announce every member
of parliament will testify that potholes
are high on the public's list of
concerns so as autumn takes hold I am
making an additional 420 million pounds
available immediately
immediately to local highway authorities
to tackle potholes bridge repairs and
other minor works in this financial year
but mr. Deputy Speaker if we want
sustainable world-class public services
and rising living standards we must make
the serious long-term reforms our
economy needs to tackle the productivity
challenge to prepare our nation for the
technological change ahead and to show
the next generation that our market
economy can evolve once again to meet
the needs of the new age because for us
on this side of the house ending
austerity is not just about funding
public services it's about real wage
growth and it's about leaving more of
people's hard-earned money in their
pockets this is the nation of the
Industrial Revolution of Stevenson of
wittle' Lovelace and Faraday people
whose ideas shape the world around them
and today Britain once again can lead
the world as we exploit a new wave of
scientific and technological discovery
pouring out of our universities and
research institutes and we can solve the
productivity challenge if we are willing
to embrace the future to make the choice
to invest in infrastructure in research
in skills and in our region's to manage
change not hide from it mr. Deputy
Speaker I I believe passionately in this
agenda but even I would admit that
perhaps at the last two budgets I might
have given the house just a little bit
more detailed information on
productivity and technological
innovation that it strictly needed so
mr. Deputy Speaker this time I'll leave
it to the budget Redbook to set out more
details of the many measures we will
take today
[Applause]
but Mr deputy seeker sensing the
disappointment of my college I will just
mention that this list in the budget red
book includes our commitment to
technology with 1.6 billion pounds of
new investments to support our modern
industrial strategy ranging from nuclear
fusion to quantum computing a hundred
and fifty million pounds for fellowships
to attract the brightest talent to these
shores from around the world so that our
scientific research continues to lead
the world and our commitment to
infrastructure expanding the national
productivity investment fund
once again to over 38 billion pounds by
2020 324 so that over the next five
years total public investment is growing
by 30 percent to its highest sustained
level in 40 years and will on average be
an astonishing 460 million pounds a week
higher in real terms than under the last
Labour government a Conservative
government mr. Deputy Speaker investing
in the roads the railways the research
and the digital infrastructure that will
power this country in the 21st century
mr. Deputy Speaker half of the UK's 600
billion pound infrastructure protein
will be built and financed by the
private sector and in financing public
infrastructure I remain committed to the
use of public-private partnership where
it delivers value for the taxpayer and
genuinely transfers risk to the private
sector but there is compelling evidence
that the Private Finance Initiative does
neither the Shadow Chancellor of course
rages against PFI at every opportunity
yet curiously forgets to mention that
nearly 90% of those contracts agreed by
the last Labour government
leaving the nation with a bill of more
than 200 billion pounds to pay off in
what would be the most potent symbol of
the economic mismanagement of the last
Labour government if only Gordon Brown
hadn't sold the gold Labour's policy is
to terminate all these contracts
triggering the ruinous penalty clauses
that they themselves agreed to in the
first place
adding tens of billions more to an
already enormous bill a classic labor
solution pouring good money after bad
I will not do that we will honor
existing contracts but the days of the
public sector being a pushover must end
we will establish a center of excellence
to actively manage these contracts in
the taxpayers interest starting in the
health center and we will go further I
have never signed off a PFI contract as
Chancellor and I can confirm today that
I never will I can announce that the
government the government will abolish
the use of PFI and pf2 for future
projects putting another legacy of
labour behind us
mr. Deputy Speaker we're investing in
our nation's infrastructure and backing
the technologies of the future but we
know that the real engine of growth is
enterprise the right honourable member
for Hazen Harlington lists fermenting
the overthrow of capitalism as his
pastime
mine is reinvigorating capitalism
because because mr. Deputy Speaker I
want Britain to be one of the great
winners of the technological revolution
on this side of the house we will always
back enterprise in the market economy
that underpins it because we know it is
the only way to deliver the high-wage
high-skill economy of the future and as
we finalize our departure from the EU
and deliver a deal that secures
Britain's future trade
we must unleash the investment that will
drive our future prosperity so today I
can announce a package of measures to
stimulate business investment and send a
message loud and clear to the rest of
the world Britain is open for business
[Applause]
mr. Deputy Speaker I am increasing the
annual investment allowance from 200
thousand pounds to 1 million pounds for
two years delivering on a long-standing
ask of the British Chambers of Commerce
I'm providing a targeted relief for the
cost of acquiring IP rich businesses and
introducing a permanent tax relief for
none for new non-residential structures
and buildings partly funded by an
adjustment in the special writing down
rate for long life assets from 8 percent
to 6 percent to better align the tax and
accounting treatment of these assets to
support British exports we will increase
UK EFS direct lending facility by up to
2 billion pounds will open the use of a
passport gates that Heathrow and other
airports currently only available to EEA
nationals to include visitors from the
United States Canada New Zealand
Australia
[Applause]
and we will provide an additional 200
million pounds of funding to the British
business bank to replace access to the
European investment fund if needed we'll
back another 10,000 entrepreneurs by
extending startup loans funding to 2021
and following representations from the
FSB I'm extending the new enterprise
allowance providing mentoring and
support for benefit claimants to get
their business ideas off the ground and
we thanks to my honourable friend the
member for Thirsk and Moulton we're
working with the FCA on expanding access
to the Financial Ombudsman service for
larger SMEs as well as backing
businesses to invest and grow we will
also make sure British workers are
equipped with the skills they need to
thrive and prosper we've introduced a
new system of tea level vocational
training have put the first hundred
million pounds into the new national
retraining Scheme and through the
apprenticeship levy we're delivering
three million high-quality
apprenticeships in this Parliament for
that system mr. Deputy Speaker is paid
for by employers and it has to work
for employers so today in addition to
the flexibilities I announced earlier
this month I can announce that for
smaller firms taking on apprentices we
will have the amount they have to
contribute from 10% to 5% in total this
is a 695 million pound package to
support apprenticeships mr. Deputy
Speaker as our economy evolves in the
digital age so too must our tax system
to ensure that it remains fair and
robust against abuse and that it raises
the revenues we need to fund our public
services the employment allowance was
introduced to incentivize businesses to
take on employees but at a flat rate of
3,000 pounds per employer it does not
provide any real incentive for larger
employers so from April 2020 we'll
target it at small and medium businesses
with an employer National Insurance bill
under one
hundred thousand pounds a year we will
also bring the treatment of capital
losses for the largest companies into
line with that of income losses mr.
Deputy Speaker where we recommit today
to keeping family homes out of capital
gains tax but some aspects of private
residence relief extend it beyond that
objective and provide relief for people
who are not using the home as their main
residence so from April 2020 we will
limit lettings relief to properties
where the owner is in shared occupancy
with the tenant and reduce the final
period exemption from 18 months to nine
months mr. Deputy Speaker I have
received representations that I should
abolish entrepreneurs relief and put the
savings towards funding our NHS
commitments but I do not believe we can
have sustainable public services unless
we have a dynamic economy and
encouraging entrepreneurs must be at the
heart of any strategy for a dynamic
economy so I will retain entrepreneurs
relief but to ensure it is going to
genuine entrepreneurs I will extend the
minimum qualifying period from twelve
months to two years mr. Deputy Speaker
in the period since the last budget
we've explored all avenues to address
the cliff edge effect of v80
registration but our options are
restricted by EU law we will continue to
work on this issue as our future v80
regime becomes clear over the years
ahead and in the meantime to give small
businesses certainty and in response to
representations from my right honourable
friend the member for mid Worcestershire
the FSB and others I will leave the
threshold unchanged for a further two
years
mr. Deputy Speaker the off payroll
working rules known as ir35
are designed to ensure fairness so that
individuals working side by side in a
similar role for the same employer pay
the same employment taxes last year we
changed the way these rules are enforced
in the public sector but widespread
non-compliance also exists in the
private sector so following our
consultation we will now apply the same
changes to private sector organizations
as well but after listening carefully to
representations made including many from
my honourable and right honourable
friends during the consultation we will
delay these changes until April 2020 and
we will only apply them to large and
medium-sized businesses mr. Deputy
Speaker there is one standout example of
where the rules of the game must evolve
now if they are to keep up with the
emerging digital economy digital
platforms delivering search engines
social media and online marketplaces
have changed our lives our society and
our economy mostly for the better but
they also pose a real challenge for the
sustainability and fairness of our tax
system the rules have simply not kept
pace with changing business models and
it is clearly not sustainable or fair
that digital platform businesses can
generate substantial value in the UK
without paying tax here in respect of
that business
the UK has been leading attempts to
deliver international corporate tax
reform for the digital age a new global
agreement is the best long-term solution
but progress is painfully slow we cannot
simply talk forever so we will now
introduce
we will now introduce a UK digital
services tax this will be a narrowly
targeted tax on the UK generated
revenues of specific digital platform
business models it will be carefully
designed to ensure it is established
tech giants rather than our tech
startups that shoulder the burden of
this new tax it is important that I
emphasize that this is not an online
sales tax on goods ordered over the
Internet such attacks would fall on
consumers of those goods and that is not
our intention the digital services tax
will only be paid by companies which are
profitable and which generate at least
500 million pounds a year in global
revenues in the business lines in scope
we will consult on the detail to make
sure we get it right and to ensure that
the UK continues to be the best place in
the world to start and scale up a tech
business the tax will come into effect
in April 2020 and is expected to raise
over 400 million pounds a year in the
meantime we will continue to work at the
OECD and the g20 to seek a globally
agreed solution and if one emerges we
will consider adopting it in place of
the UK digital services tax but this
step shows that we are serious about
this reform because mr. Deputy Speaker
it is only right that these global
Giants with profitable businesses in the
UK pay their fair share towards
supporting our public services
a mr. Deputy Speaker I am already
looking forward to my call from the
former leader of the Liberal Democrats
we're updating the rules of the game but
we must also make sure that people play
by the rules and today we continue the
work of the past eight years where we've
secured 185 billion pounds since 2010
which would otherwise have gone unpaid
with a package of measures today to
further clamp down on tax avoidance
evasion and unfair outcomes raising
another 2 billion pounds over the next 5
years we will make HMRC a preferred
creditor in business insolvencies to
ensure that tax which has been collected
on behalf of HMRC is actually paid to
HMRC we'll end the practice of
purchasing services through overseas
branches to avoid UK VAT and we'll crack
down on insurance companies routing
services through offshore territories
and will step up will stop our generous
R&D tax credit system being abused by
reintroducing a PA ye restriction for
the small and medium-sized companies
scheme mr. Deputy Speaker Labour talked
tough on tax avoidance and evasion we
take action
[Music]
mr. Deputy Speaker investing in our
infrastructure lacking the technologies
of the future supporting British
businesses updating our tax system for
the digital age that is how we will
deliver the high-wage high-skill economy
of the future but we must also recognize
that technological change will bring
challenges as well as opportunities and
there is one part of our economy that is
currently confronting that challenge in
spades our high streets embedded in the
fabric of our great cities towns and
villages the high street lies at the
heart of many communities and it is
under pressure as never before
as Britain adopts online shopping with
greater alacrity than any other large
economy so if Britain's high streets are
to remain at the center of our community
life they will need to adapt today we
support them to do so responding to
calls from across this house especially
from my right honourable friend the
member for Putney and my honourable
friends the members for Southport and
Croydon south we will provide 675
million pounds of CO funding to create a
future high streets fund to support
councils to draw up formal plans for the
transformation of their high streets
to invest in the improvements they need
and to facilitate redevelopment of
underused retail in commercial areas
into residential but one on the same
time mr. Deputy Speaker helping with the
housing challenge and delivering
much-needed football to high street
businesses we will consult on how
modernization of the use classes order
and the CP o regime can help facilitate
the transformation of the high street
mr. Deputy Speaker the change that our
high streets face is irreversible and it
will take them time to adapt to it but I
know that many small retail businesses
are struggling to cope with the high
fixed costs of business rates since 2016
we've introduced business rates relief
measures worth 12 billion pounds and
many of these reliefs will have
benefited High Street businesses but
today I can go further at the next
revaluation in 2021 ratable values will
adjust to reflect changes in rental
values but I want to help retail
businesses now so for the next two years
up to that revaluation for all retailers
in England with a rateable value of 51
thousand pounds or less
I will cut their business rates bill by
1/3
[Music]
[Applause]
that is an annual saving of up to eight
thousand pounds for up to 90% of all
independent shops pubs restaurants and
cafes
[Applause]
I will also extend the 1500 pound local
newspaper discount for a further year
mr. Deputy Speaker whatever the National
Press says I've been assured of a warm
welcome
for my budget from the Royston Crow and
the Kazakh reminder mr. Veblen speaker
local authorities have long been able to
provide discretionary business rates
relief to other bodies but not to
themselves and so following
representations from my honorable
friends for North Cornwall and st.
Austell anuki I'm pleased to announce a
new mandatory business rates relief for
public lavatories so that so that local
authorities can at last relieve
themselves
for the for the convenience of the house
mr. Deputy Speaker
and without wishing to get unduly bogged
down on this subject
this relief the house will be interested
boughs will be interested to know that
this relief well at least I'm
demonstrating that we are all British
Santa this relief will extend to any
such facilities made available for
public use
whether publicly or privately owned and
honestly mr. Deputy Speaker I can say
that this is virtually the only
announcement in this budget that hasn't
leaked mr. Deputy Speaker
it's to their policing
mr. Deputy Speaker we can't resolve the
productivity challenge or deliver the
high standards of living the British
people deserve without fixing our
housing market in last year's budget I
launched a five-year forty four billion
pound housing program to deliver the
biggest increase in housing supply since
1970 and I abolish stamp duty for
first-time buyers on properties up to
three hundred thousand pounds 120 one
thousand five hundred first-time buyers
have already benefited from our new and
the number of first-time buyers is at an
11-year high today I'm extending this
relief to all first-time buyers of
shared ownership properties valued up to
five hundred thousand pounds and I will
make this relief retrospective so that
any first-time buyer who has made such a
purchase since the last budget will
benefit but we have more to do so I can
announce today a further five hundred
million pounds for the housing
infrastructure fund to unlock a further
six hundred and fifty thousand homes the
next wave of a strategic partnerships
with nine housing associations which
will deliver 13,000 homes across England
up to a billion pounds of British
business bank guarantees to support the
revival of SME house builders we're
consulting on simplification of the
process for conversion of commercial
property into new homes and because we
want to see parishes and neighbourhoods
enabling more homes for sale to local
people to buy at prices they can afford
with providing funding to empower up to
500 neighbourhoods to allocate or
permission land for housing through the
neighbourhood planning system for sale
at a discount to local people in
perpetuity
I'm also grateful to my right honorable
friend the member for West Dorset for
his review of build-out rates published
today he concludes that the large house
builders are not engaged engaged in
systematic speculative land banking and
he makes several recommendations
well maybe the Honourable lady I'd like
to read the report he makes several
recommendations for reform of the
planning system in respect of very large
strategic housing sites and we will
respond in full to his report in the new
year mr. Veblen speaker meeting the
productivity challenge means tapping the
potential of every region and nation our
devolution agenda is giving power back
to the people and today we go further to
fire up the northern powerhouse fuel the
Midlands engine and back our regions
across the UK we're increasing the
transforming cities fund to 2.4 billion
pounds and providing an additional 90
million pounds to trial new models of
smart transport including on-demand
buses
I think mr. Deputy Speaker that's what
we used to call in our day taxis we're
launching a competition for proposals
for business led development
corporations we're funding 10 University
Enterprise Zones
there's a hundred and 15 million pounds
for digital catapults in the Northeast
Northern Ireland and the southeast and
the medicines discovery catapult in
orderly 70 million pounds to develop the
defence and national rehabilitation
center near Loughborough 37
37 million pounds of additional
development funding for northern
powerhouse rail and 10 million pounds
for a new pilot in Manchester to support
the self-employed to acquire new skills
we're backing a new special economic
area in South T's and we're providing 20
million pounds to further develop the
plan for the critical central section of
east-west rail between Oxford and
Cambridge and here in our capital we
support the delivery of a further 19,000
homes by improving the Docklands Light
Railway with housing infrastructure fund
money mr. Deputy Speaker the decisions
announced in this budget means in 2021
an additional 950 million pounds for the
Scottish Government 550 million pounds
for the Welsh government and 320 million
pounds for a Northern Ireland Executive
obviously much larger sums to come as we
move ahead over the spending review
period with our NHS funding change I can
also announced funding for further city
and growth deals including a hundred and
fifty million pounds for teh city's 350
million pounds for Belfast on a hundred
and twenty million pounds for North
Wales while negotiations progress with
Ayrshire Mid Wales and Borderlands and
we'll begin with Murray Derry
Londonderry and Strabane as well I was
pleased to be able to respond to a joint
request from the members for Belfast
north Belfast East and Belfast south to
provide
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to provide the city to provide the city
with two million pounds help towards the
recovery of the city center following
the fire at the iconic Bank built banks
building and we're also moving forward
with schools projects in Northern
Ireland worth 300 million pounds to
increase the provision of shared and
integrated cross community education
and we've agreed to the establishment of
a working group to progress plans for
shortfall APD devolution to continue to
support Scotland's oil and gas industry
we will maintain headline tax rates at
their current level and launched a call
for evidence on our plan to make
Scotland a global hub for
decommissioning and finally to support
our vital fishing industry as we leave
the EU will invest 12 million pounds
over the next three years in
cutting-edge Fisheries technology and
safety measures a Conservative
government mr. Deputy Speaker delivering
for all our proud nations and for all
our English regions driving growth and
prosperity across our United Kingdom mr.
Deputy Speaker we are driven by a
determination to ensure that the next
generation will be more prosperous than
ours but we cannot secure our children's
future unless we secure our planets
future so at this budget I take further
action with a package of measures set
out in the red book to ensure that we
leave our environment in a better state
than we inherited it there is one
particular measure I want to mention the
shadow Chancellor's recent accident has
reminded us all how dangerous abandoned
waste can be so I will provide ten
million pounds to deal with abandoned
waste sites although I cannot guarantee
to the house that ten million pounds is
going to be enough to stop him falling
flat on his face in the future
[Music]
mr. Deputy Speaker I also said at the
spring statement that we must become a
world leader in tackling the scourge of
plastic littering our planet and our
oceans billions of disposable plastic
drinks cups cartons bags and other items
are used every year in Britain
convenient for consumers but deadly for
our wildlife and our oceans where we
cannot achieve reuse we are determined
to increase recycling so we will
introduce a new tax on the manufacture
and import of plastic packaging which
contains less than 30% recycled plastic
transforming the economics of
sustainable packaging we will consult on
the detail and implementation timetable
I have also looked carefully at the case
for introducing a levy on the production
of disposable plastic cups not just for
coffee but for all types of beverage I
have concluded that attacks in isolation
would not at this point deliver a
decisive shift from disposable to
reusable cups across all beverage types
I will monitor carefully the
effectiveness of the action which the
takeaway drinks industry is already
taking to reduce single-use plastics and
I will return to this issue if
sufficient progress is not made but in
parallel my right honourable friend the
Environment Secretary will look to
address this issue through the reform of
the packaging producer responsibility
scheme working across government this
ambitious package reflects our
determination to lead the world in the
crusade to rid the oceans and the
environment of plastic waste
mr. Deputy Speaker it is only by dealing
with our debts and tackling the
long-term challenges our country faces
that we can sustainably raise wages and
living standards but I recognize that
many people are feeling pressure on
their household budgets now and because
the hard work of the British people is
paying off I am pleased to be able to
announce today a series of measures to
help families across Britain with the
cost of living mr. Deputy Speaker
turning first to duties as my right
honourable friend the Prime Minister has
already announced we will freeze fuel
duties for the ninth successive year
bringing the total saving to the average
car driver to over 1,000 pounds and to
the average van driver to over 2,500
pounds the tobacco Duty escalator will
continue to rise at inflation plus 2
percent mr. Deputy Speaker I've received
numerous representations from my
honourable and right honourable friends
on one particular subject and in
response I will be freezing beer and
cider duty
keeping the cost of beer down for
patrons of the great British pub and in
response to the concerted lobbying of my
Scottish Conservative colleagues I will
also freeze duty on spirits
so that we can all afford to raise a wee
dram to Ruth Davidson on the arrival of
baby beer
saving to pee on a pint of beer one pee
on a pint of cider and 30p on a bottle
of scotch or gin compared to the
inflation assumption in the OB our
forecast while proceeding with the usual
our beer RPI increases on wine as
promised at autumn budget 2017 so called
white ciders will be taxed at a new
higher rate from October next year I can
confirm that we will increase remote
gaming duty on online games of chance to
21% in order to fund the loss of revenue
as we reduce table tea stakes to 2
pounds from April 20 20 APR 8
and the new 26:30 rail card which I
announced at budget last year will be
available across the network by the end
of the year saving up to 4.4 million
young people 1/3 of their fares
and we launched a package of measures on
affordable credit and support for credit
unions which is set out in detail in the
Redbook mr. Deputy Speaker the switch to
universal credit is a long overdue and
necessary reform
[Music]
it replaces the broken system left by
the last layer
a system mr. Deputy Speaker that trapped
millions on out-of-work benefits today
this is not just a welfare measure it is
a major structural reform to our economy
that will help to drive growth and
employment in the years ahead when I pay
tribute to my right honourable friend
the member for Chingford without whose
tenacity
without whose tenacity universal credit
would never have seen the light but I
recognize the genuine concerns among
many honorable and right honourable
friends about two issues first the
implementation of this program it is it
is an enormous undertaking and we've
always been clear we want the migration
process to be as smooth as possible
I have already delivered nearly 3.5
billion pounds to help with the
transition including a 1.5 billion pound
package of support at last year's budget
today I can go further with a package of
additional measures worth 1 billion
pounds over five years enabling what a
surprise mr. Deputy Speaker what a
surprising response from the opposition
front page a package of measures to aid
the transition worth 1 billion pounds
over five years enabling my right
honourable friend the Secretary of State
for Work and Pensions to introduce
additional protections as existing
welfare claimants move on to UC and she
will announce details when she
introduces the managed migration
regulations later this year secondly I
have heard the concerns about the rates
and allowances within the design of the
system in my first autumn statement I
reduced the UC taper rate from 65% to
63% and today I can tell the house that
I am increasing work allowances in
universal credit by 1,000 pounds per
annum at a cost of 1.7 billion pounds
annually once
rollout is complete benefiting 2.4
million working families with children
2.4 million working families with
children and people with disabilities by
630 pounds per year mr. Deputy Speaker
Universal Credit is here to stay
we are putting in the funding it needs
to make it a success
because on this side of the house we
believe that work should always pay mr.
Deputy Speaker delivering higher wages
for those in work is core to my mission
as Chancellor under this conservative
government the poorest 20% have seen
their real incomes grow faster than the
richest 20% and the proportion of jobs
that are low paid is at its lowest level
for 20 years thanks to the national
living wage introduced by a Conservative
government
from April it will rise again by 4.9%
from seven pounds 83 to 8 pounds 21
handing a full-time worker a further six
hundred and ninety pounds annual pay
increase and taking his or her total pay
rise since the introduction of national
living wage to over two thousand seven
hundred and fifty pounds a year we also
accept the low pay commission's
recommendations on national minimum wage
rates supporting young people and
apprentices with further above inflation
increases the current remit for the low
pay Commission is for the national
living wage to reach 60 percent of
median earnings by 2020 subject to
sustained economic growth but next year
we will need to give the low pay
Commission a new remit beyond 2020
we will want to be ambitious with the
ultimate objective of ending low pay in
the UK but we will also want to be
careful protecting employment for lower
paid workers so we will engage
responsibly with employers the tea you
see and the low pay Commission itself
over the coming months gathering
evidence and listening to views to
ensure that we get this right and I will
confirm the final remit at the budget
next year but as well as making
as well as making
[Applause]
I hear the Honorable lady mr. Deputy
Speaker but our point is slightly
blunted by the fact that she made it in
the autumn of 2016 she made it again in
the spring
[Applause]
in the autumn of
mr. Deputy Speaker as well as making
work pay we want working people to keep
more of the money they earn when we came
into office the personal allowance tat
at six thousand four hundred and
seventy-five pounds and the higher rate
threshold of forty three thousand eight
hundred and seventy five pounds in April
I raised the personal allowance to
eleven thousand eight hundred and fifty
pounds and the higher eight threshold to
forty six thousand three hundred and
fifty as steps towards our manifesto
commitments of twelve thousand five
hundred and fifty thousand respectively
by 2020 those manifesto commitments were
of course made before our new funding
pledged to the NHS and I have received
representations that the least painful
way for taxpayers to contribute to
increased NHS funding would be to
abandon our manifesto pledges and freeze
the personal allowance and the higher
rate threshold at current levels but let
me reassure the house that unlike the
right honourable gentleman opposite my
idea of extending of ending austerity
does not involve increasing people's tax
bills
I didn't come into politics to put taxes
up and the improvement we have delivered
in the public finances means that based
on the OB R's forecast published today I
do not need to do so I can therefore
confirm today that I will meet our
manifesto commitments in April 2020
rising the personal allowance to 12,500
pounds and the higher rate threshold to
50,000 pounds before indexing both in
line with inflation from 21 22
but our careful management of the
economy allows me to go further so I
will raise both the personal allowance
and the higher rate threshold to these
levels from April 2019
[Applause]
delivering our manifesto commitments one
year early a tax cut for 32 million
people 130 pounds in the pocket of a
typical basic rate taxpayer meaning
since 2015 we've taken 1.7 million
people out of tax altogether our nearly
1 million people out of higher rate tax
a mr. Deputy Speaker as a result of the
announcements I have made today a single
parent receiving universal credit and
working 25 hours a week on national
living wage will benefit by eight
hundred and ninety pounds next year the
hard work of the British people paying
off in hard cash in their pockets mr.
Deputy Speaker we have turned an
important corner and now we must pull
together to build the bright prosperous
future that is within Britain's grass if
we choose to seize it embracing change
not hiding from it building on the
inherent strength of the British economy
and the indomitable spirit of the
British people mr. Deputy Speaker under
this conservative government austerity
is coming to an end but discipline will
remain
austerity is coming to an end but
discipline will remain and that is the
clear dividing line in British politics
today between a Conservative government
delivering on the British people's
priorities supporting our public
services investing in Britain's future
keeping taxes low and getting our debt
down or the Corbin party whose idea of
ending austerity is to raise taxes to
their highest level in peacetime history
who would send out that soaring who
would squander the hard work one
achievements of the past eight years and
take this country back to square one we
are at a turning point in our history
and we must resolve to go forwards not
backwards and work together to build a
Britain that we can all be proud of
I commend this statement today
[Applause]
[Music]
under standing order number 51 the first
motion entitled provisional collection
of taxes must be decided without debate
will the Chancellor of the Exchequer
please move formally formally mr.
Dettman speaker the question is the
pursuant of section 5 of the provisional
collection of taxes at 1968 provisional
status tree effect shall be given to the
foot to the following motions Hey stamp
duty reserve tax like it's listed
securities and connected persons bracket
motion number 49 b2 biker brother
[Applause]
can I just takes one rule that moves
multiple languages to listen to or three
to affect their constituents
I will say once again the Honorable
members may be interesting what affects
the constituents because I certainly am
we will know what affects them and what
does until I could complete it a lettuce
completes it and I don't need any help
from the night bed chief right as many
of that opinion say aye
the country no I think the ice of eight
the eyes have AIDS
I know call upon I know call upon the
Chancellor the Exchequer to move the
merchant entitled income tax brackets
George it is on the motion that the
debate will take place today and on
succeeding days the questions on this
motion and on the remaining motions will
be put at the end of the budget debate
on Thursday the first of November
minister to me the quest is the income
tax charged for the tax year twenty
nineteen twenty and declared that it is
expedient and in the public interest
that this resolution should have
statutory effect under the provisions of
the reficul collection of taxes I I know
called the leader of the Opposition the
right honourable Jeremy Corbyn
[Applause]
mr. Deputy Speaker the reality is
whatever the chance the claims today
austerity is not over
and far from building a strong economy
eight years of austerity has damaged our
economy delayed and weakened the
recovery and endlessly postponed fixing
the deficit unnecessary austerity has
caused real hardship to millions of our
fellow citizens held down living
standards with agility and failed on its
own terms mr. Deputy Speaker people have
had enough or just an older kid the
public is ditching it can I just say but
we heard the Chancellor of the Exchequer
I expect to hear the leader of the
Opposition those who may have been put
themselves in a position thinking I
can't see them yes I can and I don't
want to hear anymore
I won't see the chance of the Exchequer
in the same way that your constituents
do Jeremy Corbyn Thank You mr. Deputy
Speaker the Prime Minister pledged
austerity is over this mr. Deputy
Speaker is a broken promise budget
[Music]
what we've heard today 1/2 measures and
quick fixes while austerity grinds on
and far from people's hard work and
sacrifices having paid off as the
Chancellor claims this government has
fretted it away in ideological tax cuts
to the richest in our society
this budget won't undo the damage done
by eight years of austerity and doesn't
begin to measure up to the scale of the
job that needs to be done to rebuild
Britain the government claims austerity
has worked so now they can end it but
that is absolutely the opposite of the
truth austerity needs to end because it
has failed just two years ago he
forecast growth of 2.1 percent next year
and the year after
today he boasts he's created robust ik
economic growth but the forecasts have
been dropped to just 1.6 percent next
year at one point for the year after
economic growth in the first half of
this year was the slowest since 2011 the
last year we had only had the lowest
growth of any major economy this is not
a strong economy but a weak one with
chronically low investment low wages and
low productivity
and mr. Deveny speaker the uncertainty
caused by this government's shambolic
handling of brexit is making things even
worse the warnings come mr. Boyd mr.
bill pay expect better you're very
obviously right in my sight so I suspect
you either gold quietly out of the
chamber if you can't behave Jeremy
Konner very good the warnings come from
across the economy the car industry
farming and food road haulage UK
manufacturing is currently in recession
so much for the much-vaunted
March of the makers mr. Deputy Speaker
they said austerity would mean the
deficit would close by 2015 today the
Chancellor has confirmed it will still
be there nine years later in 2024 even
now great chunks of the deficit have
simply been parked off two others not
eradicated moved into the accounts of
NHS trusts shoveled onto the books of
local councils that have collapsed with
many more on the brink and most
worryingly
and frightening for many people loaded
onto the very fast rising levels of
personal and household debt
for too long the party opposite peddled
the myth that the last Labour government
crushed the economy by overspending on
public services
[Applause]
[Music]
as if mr. Deputy Speaker investing to
bring health spending as the last Labour
government did up to European levels had
caused the global financial crash
[Music]
mr. speaker on this side of the house we
believe that spending on public services
is an investment that benefits the
health of our people and the economy of
our country this morning the health
secretary said that it would take a
generation to achieve parity of esteem
of mental health and refused to say
whether the money was ring-fenced and
that money is only half of what leading
mental health experts say is necessary
but mr. Deputy Speaker the impact of
austerity on our people's health is more
than the NHS funding improvements in
life expectancy are stalling for the
first time in modern history and in the
poorest areas of our country life
expectancy is actually falling and child
mortality is rising the National Health
Service our precious National Health
Service is a thermometer of the
well-being of our society but the
illness is austerity cuts to social care
failure to invest in housing and
slashing of real Social Security it has
one inevitable consequence people's
health has got worse and demands on the
National Health Service have increased
1.4 million elderly people not getting
the care they need Tory cuts have taken
seven billion seven billion mr. Deputy
Speaker from Social Care budgets today's
announcement is a drop in the ocean both
the adult and child social care
and at this time of rising demand nurse
numbers are falling GP numbers are
falling health visitor numbers are
falling and there are 10,000 vacancies
for doctors in our National Health
Service under the last Labour government
the NHS budgets averaged an increase of
6% a year that's been slashed to just
one point four percent under this
government the Health Foundation says
the government's much-heralded extra
money for the National Health Service is
and I quote simply not enough while the
IFS says funding at this level will only
maintain current levels and let's
remember what the current levels are in
the NHS record waiting times at accent
emergency
mr. hor I think we know better we caught
each others arrive before I won't want
to catch it again
seriously you might think Halloween's
for screaming it is not what I want here
in this chamber 4.3 million people on
National Health Service waiting lists
longer waits to start cancer treatment
we need to go further which is why as we
pledged in our manifesto labour will
raise taxes for highest earners to fund
an increase above the government's
baseline but mr. Deputy Speaker it's not
only the National Health Service that is
in crisis defense spending has actually
been cut the size of the army has been
cut by a fifth and whilst we welcome the
donation based
whilst we welcome the donation based on
v80 games to commemorate the arm assists
and 1.7 more million for educational
programs to ensure people learn the
horrors of the Holocaust and I join with
the Chancellor in absolutely condemning
the horrific and vile anti-semitic and
racist attack that occurred in
Pittsburgh over the weekend we stand
together with those under threat from
the far-right wherever it may be any way
on this planet
[Music]
the Conservatives the Conservatives used
to claim to be the party of law and
order now they can't even maintain law
and order in our prisons assaults at
record levels as depleted staff tried to
cope with a difficult situation and our
streets are less safe to police numbers
it down violent crime is up and
convictions are down chief constables
are warning that criminals are taking
advantage and police officers are having
to take the government to court the
police officers taking the government to
court just to get a pay rise after eight
years of austerity firefighters today
are paid six thousand seven hundred
pounds less than they were ten years ago
nurses 4750 teachers
4650 every public sector worker deserves
a decent pay rise but mr. Deputy Speaker
60% of teachers are not getting it
neither are the police nor the
government's own civil service workers
cleaners and security guards in a
Ministry of Justice and the Department
of Business still aren't even getting
the London living wage
mr. Deputy Speaker the gap between those
at the very top and the rest is not
closing it's growing the pay of chief
executives of our biggest companies rose
by 11% this year paying themselves a
hundred and forty to five times more
than the workers in the companies that
they lead at the other end of the scale
six point three million workers are paid
less than the real living wage up three
hundred thousand in the last year alone
the very lowest earners and insecure
workers on zero hours contracts or short
hours contracts will not benefit from
the increase in the threshold and they
are the very people being punished by
the cuts still hardwired into universal
credit the Chancellor boasts of a
balanced approach but what is balanced
about cutting Social Security for
disabled people or slashing services to
the bone but when by the end of this
Parliament they will have doled out a
hundred and ten billion pounds in tax
giveaways to corporations and the
super-rich meanwhile meanwhile in the
real world homelessness has more than
doubled fewer people able to buy a home
household debt rising child poverty is
up now to over four million and rising
and more disabled people are living in
poverty also far from tackling the
burning in justices as the prime
minister said her government was going
to do they have actually made them worse
and increase the injustice in our
society the equalities and Human Rights
Commission warned just last week that
Britain is becoming a two-speed society
all right for the richest few and
failing for the many this government is
harsh on the weak and feeble with a
strong they labeled good people
scroungers and sky vers while they
imposed punitive sanctions demeaning
assessments and a benefits freeze none
of which has been reversed today the
Universal Credit is causing increases in
poverty food bank use rent arrears and
homelessness when even the Work and
Pensions secretary admits that some
people will be worse off and the
architect of universal credit says the
system is underfunded then it was
inevitable the Chancellor would have to
act though he's only reversing barely
half of the cuts made however the
problems of universal credits are also
structural harming the self-employed
loan parents people with larger families
and survivors of domestic abuse that is
why we believe the rollout must be
halted immediately mr. Deputy Speaker
since 2010 86% of the cuts through tax
and benefit measures have come from
women and there was not even recognition
let alone money set aside for the women
born in the 1950s who've been denied
pension justice
women in Britain today have just one
fifth of the pension wealth of men in
part because of the grotesque gender pay
gap which at current wait rates will not
close until 2073
and there was no extra money to fund
women's refuges a lifeline for women
fleeing from domestic abuse since 2010
almost 1/5 of all refuges have been
forced to close and mr. Deputy Speaker
months after the scale of the Windrush
scandal became clear the Chancellor has
failed to set up a hardship fund for
those affected let alone the
Compensation Scheme for the hundreds of
people wronged by the Prime Minister's
nasty and perverse hostile environment
and we heard no guarantees for older
people free t TV licences for the over
75 s remain at risk by the government
that threatened to tear up the triple
lock take away the winter fuel allowance
from millions and force people in need
to pay for care at home mr. Deputy
Speaker a country that fails its young
people is failing its own future schools
funding per pupil has been cut by 8
percent the college budget has been
slashed and the adult skills budget has
been hacked by 45 percent and there are
a hundred and twenty three thousand
children in this country living in
temporary accommodations causing them
unbelievable levels of stress and
uncertainty and consequently often
underachievement
in schools Children's Services faced a 2
billion funding gap we now have the
highest number of children being taken
into care since 1985 last Saturday I
visited North City Children's Centre in
Norwich threatened with closure due to
council cuts with too many children and
Shaw Start centers already closed
the users that wonderful Center were
very frightened of their future because
they had benefited like so many others
have in so many other parts of the
country from the great achievement of
the last Labour government which was
children centres and the Shore Start
initiative all over the country spending
on youth services has fallen by 62% 600
youth centres have closed there are
3,500 fewer youth workers the UK mr.
Deputy Speaker is the only major global
economy in which investment is falling
UK business investment is the lowest in
the g7 this failure to invest means
Britain's productivity is 15% lower than
major economies public sector investment
is over 18 billion lower than it was in
2010 Britain is the most regionally
unequal country in Europe with six of
the ten poorest regions in Northern
Europe in this country and the
government reinforces these disparities
let's just take an example when it comes
to transport funding the North receives
2,500 less per person than London well
people in the Midlands get 1,900 less so
much so much for the northern powerhouse
and the Midlands engine
local economies are also struggling mr.
Deputy Speaker over a hundred thousand
retail jobs have been lost in the last
three years there are 25,000 boarded up
premises across Britain a visit to many
of our high streets is to see
roller-blind shutters on shops that have
been closed because of job losses and
the problems they face the Chancellor's
business rate announcement today only
unpicked his own disastrous revaluation
last year and the Chancellor has again
delayed slashing the maximum stake on
fixed odds betting terminals but he will
not solve the crisis on our high streets
until he firstly tackles the
institutionalized tax avoidance of big
online retailers his digital services
tax announced today is too little and
too late
secondly the Chancellor must tackle the
levels of household debt driven by low
wages high streets won't thrive until
people have money to spend so we hope he
will endorse our call for the minimum
wage to be a real living wage of at
least 10 pounds an hour by 2020 and
removing the discriminatory youth rates
from the system mr. Deputy Speaker this
Chancellor has again failed to back
Labour's plan to create a national
investment bank with Regional
Development Bank's today's announcement
on broadband investment is a very small
step but Britain Brandt ranks 35th in
the global rankings of broadband speeds
currently just 2 percent of UK premises
premises have full fibre broadband
compared to 80 percent in Spain and a
hundred percent in South Korea this
government still lacks any meaningful
strategy for creating high skilled jobs
in every region and nation and failing
abysmally to invest in the industries of
the future necessary to tackle climate
change the IPCC report this month was
clear on the consequences we can only
avoid climate catastrophe if we act now
the government's response has been to
cut support for our solar industries
like losing 12,000 jobs in the process /
the building of onshore wind cut
subsidies for electric vehicles sell off
the green investment bank and instead to
back fracking in the face of
overwhelming local and scientific
opposition 10 years ago it was a Labour
government that passed a climate change
act world-leading legislation to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions by 80% by 2050
this government is not even on target to
do that clean energy investment fell 56%
last year and the UK produces less of
our energy from renewables than Germany
in France or Italy this government is I
believe mr. deputy speaking of failing
to protect our environment and in doing
so failing to protect all of our futures
the extra 500 million announced today to
help the government cope with brexit is
not about planning but about panic and
that panic is very deep-rooted yesterday
the Chancellor said another budget would
be necessary to set out a new economic
strategy in the event of an Odile brexit
this morning the Prime Minister said all
these spending commitments are funded
irrespective of a deal it's very clear
mr. speaker if they can't agree a good
deal with the EU it's because they can't
agree a deal amongst themselves in the
cabinet before in the Tory party so as
we approach the crucial stage of the
government's bungled brexit negotiations
we face a choice about the sort of
economy we want some on the benches
opposite fantasize about taking Britain
down the road and path to being a
Singapore style tax haven with a race to
the bottom in rights and protections
that must be rejected outright what we
need is an active government that will
invest in our people in every region and
every nation of our country that will
use the wealth we create to fund
world-class public services what's
needed mr. Deputy Speaker is a real
break with austerity and a government
committed to raising investment across
the board to rebuild our economy
communities and public services that is
a route to a country that could work for
all austerity is not over and the quick
fixes and half measures we've heard
today do not begin to measure up to the
scale of the job that needs to be done
to rebuild Britain
turn this select committee of the
Treasury Nicky Morgan mr. Deputy Speaker
thank you very much indeed it must be
something that I've said does everybody
leaves the the chamber or perhaps
something that she all right on remember
what isn't a North did not say because
the Chancellor had a difficult job today
he had a conflicting economic outlook as
he prepared today's budget but he has
offered solutions and a vision for the
future
unlike the leader of the Opposition from
here we have heard